wrote
the folders were arrayed by agents not
just arrayed by agents at mar-a-lago
after being removed from what the filing
indicated was mr trump's office
they were not discovered scattered on
the floor joining us now is chris
bedford senior editor at the federalist
chris is there any reason why let's say
donald trump's lawyers couldn't be
present
if the doj was just going to publish the
documents all over the internet what do
you make of the charade
i think the doj is on its heels right
now they actually believe that after
seven years of totally lying to the
american people over and over again
being able to pull the pull the wool
over republicans eyes over and over
again getting good republicans like
senator jeff sessions or attorney
general jeff sessions to stand back
people like mitt romney to vote for
impeachment that people were still going
to buy this and buy their secrets after
they raided the president's house which
is something if you're raiding a
political opponent's house you better
have a darn good reason you better be
very outright with it but especially
after seven years of lying first i tried
to say it was secrets then they said the
nuclear word as if that would just scare
everyone into it then they even had some
of their former agents imply that this
had something to do with actual russian
spying then they released that fake and
completely empty affidavit and now
they're coming out with this picture
this arrayed picture of documents
they have not made a case to the
american people and the onus is on them
they've already become an internet meme
and thank goodness finally republican
senators and congressmen and pundits are
immediately no one's sitting on their
hands and saying let's wait and see
everyone's looking at the doj and the
fbi and saying you show the evidence
because if you raid your political
opponent's house in the united states
you better have a darn good reason and
you better prove it to us and not just
say it's too secret for the kids
well
yet the chairman of the january 6th
committee yet another effort to attempt
to topple donald trump said no nothing
to see here the fbi it's all above board
listen
i trust the fbi uh they're just doing
their job it's not a partisan effort and
so
uh the
mar-a-lago thing
concerns me i don't know if some of the
material
uh he carried mar-a-lago compromises our
national security
so it's not a partisan effort because
they're doing our bidding
you mentioned russia how much of this
comes back to
an ever never-ending obsession with
russiagate that they just can't quit
that those secrets are going to sit in
those files until donald trump could
personally deliver him to vladimir putin
that's what they've always believed and
you know i would give chairman thompson
the benefit of the doubt had this
happened seven years ago i think a lot
of the american public would where if
the fbi raided someone as prominent at
former president trump's home they'd say
oh my gosh what happened something
really bad but we know better now
because we've seen the see the stefan
helper lives have come across come apart
the steele dossier has come apart fbi
agents have been have dishonored
themselves they've been forced to resign
people have walked out of the building
over this sort of stuff they don't have
our trust anymore the fbi and you know
that's actually healthy the american
public should not just look at the fbi
arresting or raiding political opponents
homes rating in this case and say well
that's okay we trust them we should
demand answers and it's the onus is
absolutely on them and i like the
democratic party has changed from one
that questioned the fbi forever to one
that now just does their bidding because
the fbi seems to be working with them
but right now the the plurality of
independence according to polling and
the majority of republicans are saying
hold on fbi the ball's in your court you
show us what you have because right now
we don't trust you
their new favorite they finally found a
law enforcement agency that they just
love finally chris thank you very much
finally appreciate your time hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else